your dad gave you some advice and i love
this because it feels like you grew up
in texas with this advice so tell
everybody what that advice is and how it
helps you so as i was stepping into the
public eye as a young creature my dad
said honey there's going to be three
ways people perceive you he said the
first group of people will adore you and
you can do no wrong
the second group of people will hate you
and you can do that right you do yeah
and then the third group of people won't
give
[Laughter]
and he said that'll be the case no
matter what so enjoy yeah
no but it's true
it's liberating to know that no matter
what i do no matter how people pleasey i
can be or fear of rejection or please
like me that no matter what there's just
no way yeah i haven't read a comment
about me that is disparaging and cruel
in 20 years oh my god so i don't i don't
do it either i think it's so because
either you're going to want to crawl in
a hole and die right or you're going to
drink your own kool-aid and we've met
them or you're going to do people yeah
to escape
no but it's it's like it's or you drink
your own kool-aid and you think like
nothing you do is like whatever so
that's just not that nothing is good no
i think it's about soliciting someone's
supportive opinion who knows you i'd
rather have someone know me well and
tell me what my growth edge might be and
have them invite me into some behavior
that might be a little terrifying okay
you know and everyone has their own
growth edge one person it might be to
show up more another person it might be
to say no more often you know so hey
thank you
i like i feel you so
i'm curious like what was the first
album you bought as a kid uh the smurf's
all-star show
yes so hip
they've escaped quite a bit i feel like
whoever is escaped a lot yeah i feel
like those smurfs too like whoever
created that they were on something
it was an interesting idea it was like
alice in wonderlandish i was like what's
happening yes and super diverse it was
cool i'm just curious like who inspired
you because well done
whoever did i mean so many people
standing on the shoulders of giants
every day i'm just constantly blown away
everything you say sounds like it came
from like a beautiful self-help book and
i love it like i'm like like you should
write when i was just like what my
growth edge am i is that my new thing
yeah
fine fine i'm gonna find my growth edge
i'm like what well you're in it yeah are
you i know i do feel like i love i love
a challenge like that though like
growing and trying something new do you
love that crunch that alchemy of
transmuting from the horror into the
inside i mean it could take decades
[Laughter]
like even what you just said i just feel
blessed i'm like wait what you're cute i
was like what
[Music]